you learned how to do long division back
in year 7 it's been a little while I
need to remind you how to do it because
long division with numbers is going to
be the pattern that we use to work out
long division with polynomials okay so
let's pick a number like say 7 let's
divide it into I don't know let's pick
something awkward like a 5041 okay so
let's do this long division let's see
how this works to get our brains back
into the space how many times does 7 go
into 5 it doesn't go any times so I
write 0 right how many times does 7 go
into 50 go 7 times
what do i do once i've written that down
i I multiply this out and then it comes
out underneath here so 7 times 7 is 49
and then I subtract which gives me 1 now
even though it's kind of implied step
it's still probably worth mentioning how
many times does 7 fit into one new times
which is why I then go to the next digit
that's what we did from 5 to 50 does
that make sense so I go to the next
digit which happens to be a full I say
ok well how many times that fit in the 8
is 2 so I multiply down and I say okay
what's 14 ok
that gives me 0 how many times does 7 go
into 0 you get the idea but I've dealt
with I've got another number hanging out
the end here
yes a 1 and and I can't there's no more
digits to call on right so this guy's
leftover it remains hence being called a
remainder okay are you happy with that
are you sure look carefully
I feel like 7 times 72 is not really or
7 times 72 or the remainder 1 isn't
really 5041 we missed something didn't
we think think how many times did 7 go
into this again ok 720 we read one now
I'm happy is that ok alright so this is
the way long division works ok think
about all the steps say there was kind
of like a looping step that happened
over
remove it again and then you finish when
you've got no more to deal with okay
when we can do exactly the same thing
with this think about where things are
this is the number you're dividing by so
what polynomial am i / it's Q it's this
guy okay so that belongs out the front
this is the polynomial I'm dividing by I
then draw my big long division sign and
underneath there is the thing that is
being divided right so this is the
divisor this is actually probably worth
writing this is the divisor down here
does anyone know what the thing being
divided is called it's called the
dividend and then what you get at the
end starts with a Q it's the question
okay so we'll get that in a second okay
it's going to end up up here okay so I'm
going to write in my dividend
it's a x squared minus 3x plus 1 okay
now think so much of this is the same as
what we just did which is why I show you
that parallel but it's sort of weird and
different okay remember I asked you how
many times a 7 go into and then I just
had to go until I could fit it in it
didn't go into 5 someone 250 okay now
here you can see this object here
remember X is a variable that's a bit
weird right so X could be like a million
or it could be a half or all that kind
of thing I don't actually know is the
tricky thing so therefore it's the most
important thing I'm only I'm actually
going to somewhat ignore this negative 4
when I think that how to divide so my
question first will be how many times
does X go into x squared and the answer
is well how many times does 5 go into 5
squared how many times does 5 go to 25
the answer is 5 times right how about
how many times does 11 go into 11
squared
121 it goes 11 times doesn't it X goes
into x squared X times however whatever
X is okay so I'm gonna write up here the
first part of my question
is X okay now um as soon as you write a
number of the top what do you do that
you have to multiply it back and then
does this sort of weird loopy thing
right so I'm gonna multiply it down
right x times X is x squared that's a
relief because meant to subtract out
right then I've got x times this guy's
well he's there as well
so I go minus 4x what I did with place
value up here I'm doing with the terms
of the polynomial okay here you've got
10 or thousands and then hundreds and
then tens and ones but here I've got x
squared terms and then X's and then the
constant term and I'm shipping down the
same way
what did I do once I write down 49 I
subtracted so I'm gonna subtract here as
well right now just watch out
subtractions negatives this is something
we have to worry about and polynomial
division that we didn't have to worry
about up here you never get negatives in
numerical division okay but you do down
here minus three X take away minus four
X double negative its X isn't it are you
with me so far you see how I did that
subtraction of course you get a zero
there that's why we chose it okay I now
ask the same question right how many
times there's X fit into X it's a once
right okay now it's worth noting that
you know just like before we bring down
the next place value ever or the next
term so there's a plus one hanging here
what do I do with this plus one over
here I multiply it by the front and now
I do another subtraction right I'm
almost there double negatives watch out
again one takeaway negative four is five
now how many times does X fit into five
and like if X is a million or it's like
we don't know right so the answer is it
doesn't fit any more times okay so this
is just the remainder now what did we
just do well let's think back to our
numerical example oh I didn't do that
right it's like going everywhere I'm
thinking oh well fingers crossed doesn't
go in my hands
what does this mean up here if 5040 1/7
gives me this what I'm saying is 5041
equals 720 lots of seven and then
there's this thing remaining on the end
the remainder yes
so what would that mean down here what
I'm suggesting is that the dividend is
equal to the divisor times there what's
it called again starts with Q the
quotient and then of course there's that
remainder hanging on let's just quickly
check it that's one of the lovely things
out are you quite good at it I'm really
good at expanding right X minus 4 X plus
1 that's a minus 4 plus 1 is minus 3
minus 4 times 1 is negative 4 plus 5 is
that what I'm supposed to end up with
notice thumbs up right it works so so
this is true statement and what I got it
out from was polynomial long division
okay numerical long division polynomial
long division question
okay so the question was is it isn't it
better to be able to take the the +5 out
and then factorize in water whatever way
is appropriate and the answer is well it
depends sometimes that's really easy to
spot I would contend for most normal
people in most cases it's not it's kind
of like well what am I supposed to do
here I'm not really sure you see this
step this this process through here
didn't require any intuition as to what
you you didn't have to anticipate what
you were going to get at the other end
okay you can you can sort of reverse
engineer this process but you don't have
to now
why man I do this well suppose this guy
here this was what I was asked to say
graph right this is something this is a
problem we encountered earlier right if
I was asked to graph that I know there's
going to be a vertical asymptote from
the denominator namely what's the
vertical asymptote look denominator
denominator wow we're a topic one guy
it's gonna be x equals four right that's
the vertical asymptote okay
this guy up here though it tells me that
there's not going to be a horizontal
asymptote it's not nice and neat
it doesn't just approach zero right it
approaches well it's off at an angle
most of it's an oblique asymptote so how
do I find that if we got into it through
whoopsie-daisy
through this process do this process
what I've just said is that this is this
so therefore up here I can replace that
x squared minus 3x plus 1 I can replace
that with that it looks like it's making
things a lot worse doesn't it it looks
like it did of this one of I got X minus
4 X plus 1 plus 5 there we go I've just
gotten rid of the original numerator but
the benefit of this is I can now break
this into two pieces right there's this
part of it sorry color there's this part
over here remember I told you to write
at the beginning some polynomials
divided by other polynomials do you give
you a nice neat polynomial at the end
right and that's the case here what do
you get left with just the X plus one
right there's been over here then you've
got the bit I have encircled in red
which is the remain
okay now as X approaches infinity tell
me what happens to this this whole
object rather as X approaches infinity
this whole object becomes zero so it
becomes insignificant what you get left
with is that guy that is your oblique
asymptote you see X plus X plus 1
there's your plank a switch eyes so if I
started to draw this thing I'd say ok
well there's my x equals 4 there's my X
plus 1 and then I'm gonna have to draw
the rest accordingly after I work out
intercepts and regions and what-have-you
ok so that's why we didn't deal with
oblique asymptotes really properly
before in the last topic because you
really need this tool to be able to work
out what on earth is going on unless
you're really lucky and it's something
we can work out without doing a proper
division